david today we turn to chapter 11 of
first corinthians where paul is talking
about
stuff that's going on in the the worship
experience of this community he'd given
some hints about worship in the last
chapter
but now he turns to it directly and they
seem to be two major issues one has to
do with um the way the women folk in
this community are behaving right and
the other has to do with something about
the way in which the um the meal is
being observed
um first of all what's going on with the
women well this is bartlett's best guess
which is based on reading lots of other
people who made their best guesses
there's some concern with the head
covering of women in church and people
aren't quite sure whether it means that
they are wearing some kind of headwear
head gear or whether it's simply the
fact that instead of having their head
decorously
looped is here's where my
entire total lack of fashion sense will
immediately show itself i have no idea
what you call this
um having a kind of nice top not curly
thing on the top of their heads they're
letting the hair flow loose in either
case paul for reasons that are hard for
us to to fathom i think thinks that it's
totally inappropriate for women to lead
in worship to join in worship uh with
that kind of
free-flowing hair let's see now you
mentioned that women are leading in
worship i think that's an important
point what why do you say that well
because it seems to me that that
the question is not just when they pray
privately but when they pray as part of
the part of the community of faith in a
kind and we'll see in chapter 14 that
the people take turns doing that kind of
thing it seems to me that this
represents a kind of leadership role not
simply a kind of
private prayer role right the fact that
uh he says praise or prophesies and he
uses prophecy is a published chapter
almost as the equivalent of preaching so
they're doing they're taking some kind
of leadership role that's not
unimportant it's not unimportant in
saying he and we'll come back to this in
chapter 14 at this point he's not saying
women be quiet in church he's saying
women when you take leadership roles in
church don't let your literally don't
let your hair down
is it perhaps because they might be
looking a little like worshipers of
dionysus yeah say a little bit about
that i think that could well be true
especially in this kind of pagan
so-called context
there's a tradition in greek culture of
the worship of the god dionysus who was
the god of wine and the god of the the
power and the vine
um and at least uh once a year um
and we know this was going on even to
paul's day uh not far from corinth
there'd be festivals at which women
would engage in ecstatic dance and we
have
pictures of of this kind of dance from
antiquity
um and the people who were engaging in
it were called meanings
and so paul might be thinking that
there's a boundary issue here rather
like the idolatry uh issue that he was
raising in the previous chapter and he's
certainly concerned here and will
continually be concerned about
appropriate visitations of the spirit
that what does the spirit do when it
comes and it's as is every as it is in
every case it is not the case with
spiritual life in church that anything
goes either that there are limits upon
this and this looks a little bit
free-floating trip there's there's a
kind of hierarchical thing that that
appears in this and i think we need to
take that head on for a moment uh
beginning with verse seven a man not
ought not to have his head veiled since
he and the he counts here is the image
and reflection of god
um
but the woman is the reflection of man
indeed man was not made from woman but
woman from man neither was man created
for the sake of woman but woman for the
sake of man this is interesting because
back in chapter seven we didn't have a
chance to talk about the issues of
marriage where it was very clear that
this this
the importance of not refraining from
sexual intercourse within marriage had
to do with the rights of both partners
there was no sense there's mutuality
total mutuality in that
mutuality seems to diminish here somehow
there's not if not a hierarchy there's a
kind of clear distinction about where
where people stand what do you think
paul does correct that though okay i
think he he has the sense yeah that this
is an argument yes he's reaching for a
number of different ideas
to get people to behave as he wants to
behave but in verse 11 nevertheless and
in the lord woman is not independent
against a man independent of woman so he
wants to uh get back to that that sense
of mutual sense in christ all
distinctions have been obliterated uh
principally articulated in galatians
on one of his best days
neither slave nor free male nor female
jew nor greek
uh so i think he's he's convinced of
that fundamentally although he'll use
this it comes well and you're right and
the punchline on all this is as woman
came from man man comes through woman
that's kind of equality but most
important all things come from god from
god
i do have a kind of hermeneutical
principle interpretive principle that
i'm not proud of but it's on a tough day
take the best of paul and interpret the
rest in the light of that uh we'll talk
another day about how we decide what the
best of paul is but galatians 3 28
is certainly at the heart of all that
now at one point here there's a very
difficult uh version that
chapter 11 verse 10. for this reason a
woman ought to have a symbol of
authority on her head because of the
angels what's going on well the only
it's a it's a huge puzzle like so many
of these things the only thing i can
think of is that is the business back in
genesis where the sons of god look down
on women from on high and lusting after
them come down and engage in
inappropriate intercourse is there some
sense that that the woman who lets her
hair loose is a loose woman and
therefore is tempting to those angels
who might i i don't know because we've
just said the angels neither marry nor
given in marriage so maybe they slip
loose once in a while ida what do you
think it's a toughy well something like
that may be going on uh it's interesting
that the term that's translated here a
symbol of authority that's exactly what
what the the word should mean it's
exclusive right in greek right yeah
often translated in the past as a veil
or something yeah
so um i think what paul is saying is if
you're exercising leadership in
christian worship uh be attentive to the
situation in which you find yourself
which is one in which you're in touch
with heaven yeah uh he goes back to
isaiah where uh the prophet uh hears the
angels
singing the truth highly on the holy
holy holy and i think that that's what
happens in christian worship you're
participating in that uh along with the
angels and so right if you're if you're
there you have to uh have some sort of
mark of authorization to do so yeah okay
and that obtains so so decorum is not
only for the body but for the communion
of something like that of heaven and
earth right brought together it's a
mysterious little passage it is a
mystery at the end of the day he says uh
finally this is just not the custom oh
yeah i do love that it's like with your
child because i said so you know finally
i've given you 16 arguments why you're
not supposed to do this p.s i said so
that's about it we don't do this as
christians so just stop it so what about
the lord's supper and what's going on
with that well this is this is an
interesting one and i've been helped by
by people who tried to understand the
sociology of the corinthian church and
like all of us they're guessing but the
issue seems to be that some people are
coming earlier than others to the meal
and are eating and drinking heartily and
then other folk come later and don't
have anything to eat and simply
participate in the kind of
bread and cup uh liturgical part of the
evening and
people have argued i think persuasively
that those who come with better food and
better drink and maybe those who can get
off from work early are not the
hard-working slaves and lower classes
but the leisure classes and what you
have
the division within the church is not
only a theological division but at this
point it's a kind of social division
that the wealthy are able to have a long
and leisurely meal together that the
less wealthy come in later and so in an
odd way the the body of christ
is inappropriately broken just before
the body of christ is appropriately
broken and and one's a good thing and
the other's a bad thing
so how does paul counter that so paul
counters that by uh first of all
reminding them of what the what the
meaning of the text of the story was and
this is another place where he goes back
to jesus uh one of the few places where
he goes back and says here's the
tradition about jesus and and what we
celebrate here is not a feast
uh not simply a good time not wednesday
night potluck at old first baptist uh
but this is a commemoration of the death
of jesus for the sake of jesus people
and in that sense uh we're to enter into
it reverently and also i think with
attention to each other
is it the case that paul almost has a
magical notion of what's going on in
this um
well what's interesting is at the very
end he talks of this chapter he talks
about the fact that because some of the
corinthians have been participating
unworthily
that they are going sick and dying i'd
defy any contemporary priest or pastor
getting up and say well a lot of
funerals in the last two or three weeks
i bet it's because we've been doing the
eucharist wrong um
is magical the right world word i don't
know in a way it goes back to what we've
been saying that faith is embodied for
him and so we always think that
spiritual mistakes have to have
spiritual consequences and those are our
distinctions i think his distinctions
are mistakes have consequences and uh
our distinction between bodily
consequences and and spiritual ones we
think of as a magic thing i think he may
just think that's the way god's world
goes right i think that's right
and truly that category of magic is
probably a little enacted
that's our way of looking at it
absolutely yeah
it's interesting to see the um the very
concrete advice he gives at the end of
all of this right i'm about to see what
it is chapter 11 verse 33
when you come together to eat well
absolutely
this points to uh this supports your
reading of what they particularly
exactly exactly right yeah um and you do
do it for the glory of god don't give
any offense to other people absolutely
and then once again be imitators of me
as i am of christ well what are they
imitating at this point they're
imitating their willingness to consider
the other
more lovingly than they simply consider
themselves it goes back to the kind of
apostle he is
to the things he's willing to give up
um the one other piece that strikes me
and this will lead us to places we've
been before uh is that when he recalls
jesus words after i think after he's
quoted the words he says as often as we
eat this bread and drink this cup we
proclaim the lord's death until he comes
and i've got two puzzles on that one i
want to put out for you
more in terms of what's yet to happen as
opposed to what has happened we proclaim
the lord's death and i think there's
some suspicion that when they get
together to have this
really big
gourmet meal before the others get there
they're thinking about resurrection
celebrations heavenly feasts if the
angels are there let's eat angelic food
and have a great time if this is still
about christ's death it's still about
sacrifice for each other not just
enjoying
a meal and the until he comes that we
are not yet fully in that heavenly
kingdom one day there'll be a banquet
at that banquet the poor and the rich
will all come together
but we're not there yet in the meantime
uh while we wait for him we think about
one another
so it brings together those two things
we've seen operating from the beginning
of this letter the focus on the cross as
the central
uh hallmark of christian belief and
practice yeah yeah that's the the the
test that's huge you have to have some
relationship to the cross exactly it's
not christian and you also have to have
some sort of sense of where it's all
going yep uh that this is leading to it
is leading to that but it's not there
yet we're still we're still waiting for
the fullness of that coming
um the other piece where he talks about
eating and drinking without discerning
the body and lots of people have
suspected that the body that's being
discerned is not
this is not
catholic protestant lutheran
presbyterian argument about what happens
to the bread and cup that's a later
discussion
it's an argument about discerning the
body in the communion around you so if
you and i get there early and have
enjoyed our gourmet meal while those
slave people and the freed persons
who've been working at our houses come
in late and have nothing to eat that's
where we're not discerning the body
we're not discerning this larger body of
christ which is where we're about to go
in chapter 12 because we're not
discerning our brothers and sisters
we're not caring for them right this is
the same sort of thing we saw it before
about temple temple
refers to the exact whole as well as to
the individual and here body language
refers to the the social unit i think so
i think the eucharistic i don't think
we're yet at disputes about what happens
when the words are spoken
it's a great it's a great text because
it does what what the communion takes a
great text because it does what i think
paul does best which is to say two
things that our liturgical life reflects
our is reflected in our forms our
theology theology is not just sitting
and thinking theology is thinking about
what we do when we come to a table and
on the other hand our theology informs
our liturgical practice it's not just
what we do it's how we understand what
we do
that's this text all right